We have a voicemail number.
The number is two one nine two.
David p received a voicemail about reparations
for black Americans.
Let's take a listen.
Hi David.
It's Mike calling and I was wondering, um,
well I watched the congressional hearing about
reparations and, um, it's very interesting
dialogue and I'm generally supportive of the
idea of reparations, but I do think that the
conversation going on right now does have
the potential to backfire against the eventual
Democratic nominee and, uh, it has potential
to ignite the far right and it is just generally
unpopular with the wider American people,
although I do think that we can make the argument
for it.
So, uh, thank you.
Yeah.
Listen, I don't know about the popularity
of reparations for black Americans among the
broader American people have not seen polling
about that.
Here's my view on it.
I think that there is a very valid and completely
reasonable, uh, moral and philosophical debate
to be had about reparations for black Americans.
How many generations after slavery does it
go?
How do you demonstrate that you are actually
descended from individuals that were slaves
in the United States rather than from families
that came to the United States after slavery
was abolished?
I'm totally up for having that discussion
in practice.
Unless Democrats get a super majority in the
Senate.
I don't see any way anyway that reparations
pass.
And thus I believe that in 2019 right now,
this is a distraction of a conversation and
I believe that it is not a pragmatically a
smart path for Democrats at large to go down.
That's, that's my view.
I don't see any way that you get a single
Republican, uh, when it comes down to voting
in the Senate, uh, or maybe more than three
or four Republicans.
Uh, I don't, I just don't see any way forward
for this.
And as a result, I don't think that it's particularly
smart politics to keep talking about this.
Uh, at this point in time.
If you disagree, I do want to hear from you.
We will talk on the bonus show today about
how Bernie Sanders would cancel student loan
debt and much, much more including how Trump
advisor Kellyanne Conway is straight up going
to not show up
to the hatch act.
Hearing that has been, uh, scheduled getting
instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member or a patron.
I will,
you done
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.